voilà donc je vais me mettre en costume
de moustiques 1 comme ici même si je
suis plus beau sur charlie d'autant vrai
les cherry et bras et on va au pair le
charlie hebdo de doha voilà madame c'est
pour vous et voilà c'est son boulot de 9
en amont marché libanais dont il donne
le char libre devant ce qu'on voit c'est
cadeau voilà vous êtes un amour ouais ça
nous va très bien ça allait mais cher il
ya tout de suite pour touche pas à mon
poste
une petite beauté en fait vous c'est
toujours plus quoi en fait pincer jamais
on n'est jamais au middle on essaie
toujours le gall fred alan gilbert bel à
la poire en homme de cro magnon la
mairie ponote je peux tu peux plus con
que j'en ai l'air je suis désolé mais je
suis choqué de l'absence totale qui êtes
choqués sont françaises ah ouais moi
aussi j'suis d'accord mais ça reste à
sincèrement c'est vrai 4,62 est facile
de chanter en anglais qu'en français
slimane je crois que c'est bien sûr
regardé dormait dans une chambre d'une
maison bleue je voulais du français du
nom de l'anglais à de l'anglais la
tenante du titre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
et ça lui va hyper bien pourri des
messages comme c'est arrivé à quoi mais
c'est un peu comme amy winehouse et elle
met les levantine vrai
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce que t'es bugs
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
donnez moi n'importe quelle chanson
prochaine française des jeux lance radio
mauvais dira seul sur le sabre voisine
en anglais abîme tué votre fils
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bharara
[Musique]
la rentrée quelle entrée quelle classe
quelle classe est entré
mais déguisé en cours on va arriver en
séries le même mais pas besoin de le
dire quoi je vais assez salut salut ma
petite beauté
je suis plus qu'à kamelan en cours de
l'or noir du tout le plaisir c'est bien
ou pas c'est ce qui a poussé un voile
est sympa et regardez regardez comme
c'est pratique up est là frédéric lopez
un autre personnage mes propositions
savais tu savais on y va on y va
ascenseur oui aussi ascenseurs et
françois les invités
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
apic un peu non mais c'est rien il a des
poux le truc bien une grosse tête
m